wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
hat es ihnen geschmeckt danke sehr gut
und die es geht
sie sind ein makler das stimmt nicht
der ziegenkäse war köstlich wunderbar
intensiv aber die scharfe wurst hat mir
nicht geschmeckt ziemlich langweilig
dafür die richtigen gewürze und
insgesamt hat mir eine raffinierte soße
gefehlt die man bei so einem gericht
einfach braucht na ja sie sind selbst
kocht da ist man kritisch um ehrlich zu
sein ich bin konditor
ich hatte eine eigene konditorei dann
sind sie der dem man morgens in der
bäckerei sieht der mann der brot und
brötchen backt und die hochzeitstorten
dekoriert aber das mache ich schon lange
nicht mehr
aber früher da habe ich die besten tag
und trocken der stadt gemacht
egal ob salzig oder süß der teig den ich
gemacht haben wir immer perfekt das
klingt super aber sie packen doch sicher
auch gern ja natürlich
welchen kuchen können sie am besten
backen marokko toll marmorkuchen ist der
kuchen die mich schon als kind gern
gegessen habe ich erst haben sie lust
auf ein dessert suchen sie etwas aus
bringen sie uns bitte noch zwei
stückchen zitronenkuchen und zwei gläser
von dem champagner den sie mir gestern
empfohlen haben
runde nicht
[Musik]